today on the matt welsh show you want to
be able to trust your child's
pediatrician but the fact is that the
entire pediatric field has been captured
by the far left you only have to do a
little bit of digging into the american
academy of pediatrics to see how bad the
corruption is we did some of that
digging and i'll tell you what we found
also biden prepares to make inflation
significantly worse with his loan
forgiveness plan a scientist tries to
explain the concept of human biology to
students at berkeley not an easy thing
to do the democrat senate candidate in
pennsylvania has actual brain damage and
can't even speak states move to abolish
forced prison labor but is that a good
idea in our daily cancellation we have a
story so incomprehensibly stupid that
you might think i'm making it up i
promise you i am not all of that and
more today on the matt walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
roe v wade has been overturned and this
battle is now finally leaving dc and
going to the grassroots no group in
america is better position than 40 days
for life to fight this battle with about
uh one million volunteers in a thousand
cities 40 days for life holds peaceful
vigils outside abortion facilities they
have a larger presence in blue states
with california being their largest
state uh some former abortion facility
directors say that these vigils can
cause the abortion no-show rate to go as
high as 75 percent which is detrimental
to their abortion business to say the
least these law-abiding vigils have
closed many abortion businesses in
america nearly half of those closed
abortion facilities were in liberal
cities where abortion will remain legal
including closures in san francisco
chicago seattle uh and other cities 40
days for life is effectively changing
hearts and minds in the grassroots to
end abortion check out their locations
podcasts and a free magazine at
40daysforlife.com
and make sure you do that because the
fight for life has really only just
begun in so many ways for more
information on 40 days for life go again
to 40daysforlife.com
recently a bewildered father posted a
video to tiktok describing a disturbing
encounter with his three-year-old's
pediatrician he said that when he
brought his son in for a routine checkup
the doctor walked into the room and
despite being able to clearly see the
child sex just by looking at him and
despite having his sex listed on the
chart he was holding in his hand the
doctor still asked the young boy whether
he was a boy or a girl listen
so we just took my three-year-old son in
the doctor for a checkup my
three-year-old son okay there's a reason
why i'm emphasizing that and you're
about to know why so my wife and i are
waiting in the room with our son and the
doctor comes in and he sees my son
sitting there on the table and the first
question that he asks him is are you a
boy or are you a girl
and i look at my wife like
luckily my son understands obvious
tenants of biology at three years old
and says that he's a boy just like his
chart says so the rest of the
appointment i can't even focus because
i'm wondering why in the world this guy
is asking the question and then i
remember oh yeah i live in california
and call me paranoid but this is where i
think we're heading based on other
things that have happened an ohio couple
lost custody of their teenager for
refusing them hormone treatment and a
divorce texas couple were in a court
battle over whether or not to let their
seven year old transition from a boy to
a girl and many are saying that the new
proposed equality act could lead to more
parents losing custody of their kids who
want gender transition
no that's not paranoid that is what we
call observant
that is in fact exactly what the doctor
is doing and many parents have had
similar experiences in recent years they
are
building a case basically that your
child is trans
what that father confronted and what so
many other parents have confronted in so
many other doctors offices across the
country is the tip of an extremely large
iceberg that stretches down into a very
dark sea
the rather terrifying fact is that the
entire pediatric field has been captured
by the far left
now there is a chance that your
pediatrician is safe and trustworthy
there are plenty of good ones left
individually
but there's also a very significant
chance that he's an agent of a radical
and dangerous ideological agenda and he
will drag your child into it if he can
and even if your pediatrician is a
competent honest health care provider
who actually believes in and abides by
the hippocratic oath to do no harm still
he's part of a system
that is run by radical leftists and
which views trans activism as the
primary responsibility of the health
care industry
even the good doctors are hostages
and your child is the ransom
now last week we discussed how the
american academy pediatrics the largest
professional association of
pediatricians with some 67 000 members
pushes medical transition onto children
doing great harm in the process and they
promote these procedures based on scant
and shoddy evidence
that's not my characterization or my
words that's what anonymous
whistleblowers within the organization
have said the academy according to some
of its own members is endorsing and
carrying out medical experimentation on
children despite the dearth of evidence
to support that approach
but the members who've made these
criticisms have been shut down and
they've been silenced their calls for an
official review of the organization's
approach to the transgender issue have
been rebuffed
all they want to do is review it they're
saying hey can we go back we look at
this and talk about it
and the organization says no we're not
going to talk about it
the aap is not interested in reviewing
or rethinking anything it does what w
path the world professional association
for transgender health tells it to do
and most recently wpath has decided that
the recommended age for giving somebody
a cosmetic double mastectomy is 15 and
the best age for cross-sex hormones is
14.
so says w path
thus so goes
the aap
in fact the deeper you dig into the
american academy of pediatrics the more
you see that this is an activist
organization masquerading as the
nation's preeminent authority on
pediatric healthcare
and we've done some of that digging here
and and we found this on the aap website
you can access their policy statement on
quote ensuring comprehensive care and
support for transgender and gender
diverse children and adolescents
now the statement is one long gender
theory manifesto littered with wild and
often incoherent assertions rooted not
in science but an ideology
worse the statement provides a sort of
um
glossary
where the definitions of meaningless
terms like gender diverse and gender
perception are provided and then it says
this
quote for more information the gender
book found at www.thegenderbook.com
is a resource with illustrations that
are used to highlight these core terms
and concepts
okay so the aap
has endorsed the gender book as not just
any resource but as an authority on core
terms and concepts
that's a problem because the gender book
is not a medical guide or a textbook or
a source of objective information but it
is rather an activist pamphlet
and i know that because the authors of
the book
said so themselves
back in 2014 the um androgynous authors
of of the book decided to punt it to
punish basically their donors by singing
a thank you song and you're gonna hear
why that's a punishment in just a second
whether you like it or not
in the song they refer to the book as
doing gender activism
so i'm sorry i have to do this to you
but here is that song
[Music]
because of you we've secured the first
round of printing of the gender book
because of you we can offer nearly 600
books back to the community
because of you the book will be launched
in 27 countries
we're doing gender activism in botswana
belgium etc
and beyond
we just want to say thank you
thank you thank you thank you
oh my gosh that was worse than i thought
now let's just leave aside the fact that
when singing um they sound like a dozen
cats drowning in a river the greater
point
is that the aap the supposed authority
on pediatric medical care
cites self-professed gender activists as
authoritative resources on core terms
and concepts
but this is to be expected after all the
aap published their very own gender book
of sorts just a few months ago
back in april the american academy
pediatrics released uology a puberty
guide for everybody
the book promotes the idea that
children can be transgender non-binary
gender diverse and so on it was authored
by three far-left activists who pretend
to be medical professionals one of whom
catherine lowe
appeared on an aap podcast back in
february to talk about the book and to
also explain why
a baby's gender cannot be determined in
the womb listen
when people are pregnant when we're
doing prenatal ultrasounds and we're
saying it's a boy or it's a girl
really we are referring to that baby's
genitals right and what we see
and we often call that a baby's sex
assigned at birth and that's actually
different than gender
so we actually aren't
able to know a baby's gender identity
prenatally we can know their genitals
and we assign a sex according to those
body parts but that really isn't gender
so someone's gender or gender identity
is really an internal core sense of who
they are as a person in regards to being
male female
maybe a little of both or neither
that is gender identity so it's more of
an internal core sense of who you are as
a person
it is not always the same as a baby's
genitals
so this is a doctor
on a podcast with other doctors hosted
by the largest pediatric association in
the country
repeating the absolutely ludicrous claim
that sex is not observed but actually
assigned
and she also draws the familiar
distinction between sex and gender but
then says that a a person's inner
experience can be male or female or a
little of both
but male and female are sexes
um
these sexes actually because there's
only two
but you see you just said that there's a
difference between sex and gender and
then you say that the sexes are genders
this is the incoherence of gender
activism and it's also the incoherence
of the medical field as the distinction
between gender activism and medicine has
been at this point almost entirely
erased
now does this mean that um well what
does it mean does it mean that you
shouldn't take your child to the doctor
anymore
well no you have to be able to take your
child to the doctor that's what makes
all this so sinister
the trans activists have kidnapped the
institutions that you rely on
and cannot go entirely without
instead what it means is that
you must exercise extraordinary caution
we all must
not blindly trusting any of these people
they do not have your child's interests
at heart
or at least you certainly cannot assume
that they do
there are other interests at work here
ideological also financial
and those interests have as we've seen
ultimately have come to outweigh
everything else especially your child's
well-being
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
some states now have laws that say as
early as the 2030 model year new
vehicles will have to be electric in
order to be registered cars with
internal combustion engines will only be
able to get license plates if they were
built before the end of the 2020s which
means that people are going to keep
repairing and driving their old cars for
generations it also means that you'd
better go to rockauto.com right now and
order all the parts to properly maintain
and repair your car your great grandkids
might be driving that car someday so you
got to make sure it's in tip-top shape
rockauto.com has been in the auto parts
business for 20 years family owned their
goal is to make auto parts available and
affordable to keep you safe on the road
rockow.com's online parts catalog is
incredibly easy to use you can search
all the parts available for your
specific car suv or truck with photo
specs and installation tips as well not
only will they have the part you need
but they're usually going to be able to
give you the trusted brands to choose
from rock autos kits are also popular
because they bundle together all the
parts you need for a successful repair
which means that you won't get halfway
through installing a timing belt only
discover that you need another pulley i
can't tell you how many times that's
happened to me when i'm installing
timing belts go to rockauto.com and get
brake shocks carpets wipers headlights
mirrors mufflers everything you need at
rockauto.com and be sure to write walsh
in there how did you hear about us box
so they know that i sent you
all right by the way i wanted to show
you this you know the hard thing about
having kids is that uh they tend to be
very honest in their assessment of you
so for example my five-year-old son drew
a picture of me yesterday i just want
i'm very proud of it he was proud of
this picture anyway so here it is you
can see it there on the screen
um
apparently
to my child i look like a character from
the nightmare before christmas i am
literally a tim burton cartoon to him
just dead lifeless eyes
i need a lot of dental work
according to him
and uh and i'm also fat
and weirdly enough i wear a suit with
cufflinks which i don't think he's ever
seen me wear ever
this is how he sees me
at least i have that cute little button
nose there maybe maybe i'm more like a
frosty as snowman's unemployed uncle
maybe that's what he was going for i'd
rather i'd rather be that i think
all right um
so we'll start here fox news reports
president joe biden is expected to
announce a much anticipated loan
forgiveness program
uh wednesday sources familiar with the
plan told the associated press americans
are poised to foot a nearly 300 billion
dollar deal with president biden's
expected announcement on wednesday to
forgive
big quotes around forgive
thousands in federal student loan debt
and extend a repayment pause to next
year according to the penn wharton
budget model a one-time maximum debt
forgiveness of ten thousand dollars for
borrowers who make less than 125 000 a
year will cost around 300 billion
dollars for taxpayers
uh the cost increases to around 330
billion if the program is continued over
the standard 10-year window according to
the figures the precise details of
biden's plan were being kept to an
unusually small circle within the bible
administration as they prepared to
announce it now this obviously is one of
the most transparent vote buying schemes
we've ever seen and to call it one of
the most transparent is saying quite a
lot i know because this is all these
people ever do
but
i actually do and i think it's important
to emphasize this
um and i it's just speaking only for
myself
i really do sympathize with people who
have student loans
um i sympathize with them
in fact i am one of them i i don't have
my own student loans because i didn't go
to college
but i've been paying off my wife's
student loans
so in effect you know two become one in
marriage so
you know and and i'm the the
income earner in the household so i i
have student loans that i'm paying off
to i didn't even go to college
so uh so i really can sympathize
i can both sympathize and and uh
uh empathize with with with people who
who have this
and i agree that
if you have these loans
you know you basically got scammed
right
most a great many people most people
with student loans got scammed you got
suckered
you took the loans on
uh you didn't understand even if it was
written in the fine print you didn't
read the fine print and if you did read
the fine print you didn't understand
what you were reading you didn't you
didn't you didn't understand all the
stuff about the interest rates and what
that's going to mean and you know it's
going to mean that you're paying back
you could pay back the loans for 15
years and um
at the end of the
pay it every month and at the end of the
15 years you've only shaved like five
thousand dollars or ten thousand dollars
off the loan because of the interest
was all there in the fine print but you
didn't understand that
uh maybe because you signed the on the
dotted line when you were 18 years old
and even worse than that
you were buying something that for so
many people is effectively worthless
you know you bought it on the promise
that if you get if you purchase this
thing which is a college degree this
piece of paper you will
be
virtually guaranteed a success a
successful life
didn't work out that way
um so you got scammed you got suckered
you for so many people bought this
worthless thing for way too much money
and you got nothing in return
except a lifetime of
debt and so i get all that
and of course i sympathize with people
in that position
but here's the point that i that i
always go back to
if you don't pay it back
somebody else will have to
so someone has to pay the loan
someone has to carry the burden
it's a burden that should not exist
but it does
it shouldn't exist because we should not
be pushing
millions of kids into this system
just as a default
strategy
and telling them hey spend a hundred
thousand dollars on a college education
and then later on figure out what to do
with it that is
madness that's total madness
shouldn't happen but it is
it did happen and it is happening
and of course most of the people talking
about student loan forgiveness
they don't want to talk about
how what to do in the future
okay because we're constantly surrounded
by morons who are just looking for
band-aid solutions that's all
politicians ever do is band-aid
solutions and unfortunately there are a
lot of really dumb people in the public
who also that's all they care about they
just want the band-aid
so we're not so you have all these give
me student loan forgiveness what what
are we doing in the future what are we
doing about this problem because just
forgiving the loans that's not going to
make the underlying problem go away it
only makes it worse
the underlying problem is that college
is ridiculously expensive and we are sh
and we are
funneling millions of kids into this
system for no good reason that's the
underlying problem we're not doing
anything about that no one's talking
about what we're gonna do about that
so we're not even having that
conversation and um so the problem's not
gonna go away but but as it pertains to
you if you have the loans well they're
there so
that's what it becomes a question of
who's going to pay them i as i said i'm
already paying my wife's loans she's my
wife i'm i'm married to her i have an
obligation to my wife
um what's hers is mine what's mine is
hers
i agreed to that when i got married to
her i didn't get married to you
okay
whoever's watching this you're not my
wife my wife is so i your obligations
are not mine
my wife's obligations are mine and vice
versa
again two become one in marriage that's
not the case for you
so
i can feel bad about the obligations
that you agreed to uh without having all
the uh without without understanding
what you're doing i feel bad about it i
do feel bad about it but it's not my
obligation it is yours
i don't know why this is so
difficult to understand i don't think it
is difficult i think people understand
it they just don't want to
understand it because
it's
because it's hard
so that's what we're left with um
the loans are there what do we do about
it the debt is there what do we do about
it
uh and no matter what you do someone is
going to suffer
and the question as always is
who should suffer
for your bad decisions
who should suffer for them should it be
you or somebody else
i don't know how you can argue for
somebody else
that's what that
i don't see how you can make that
ethical argument
and um you know talking about this and
what i've been told many times is that
well um
a couple things i'm told uh one is that
this is the federal government they're
just they're just forgiving it
whether the federal government's going
to cover it it doesn't come out of
anybody's pocket
where does the federal government's
money come from
despite how they've positioned
themselves the federal government is not
ours is not um you know
the federal government is not your daddy
who's uh got a his own wallet that he
can pull out and just
you know get you out of a bad situation
by pulling the money out of his wallet
where does the federal government's
money come from
comes from us if federal government is
covering it we are covering it
okay but then the response is well
they'll just print the money
they just print it and and you know just
like that magic
there there is in fact according to a
lot of people a magical money tree
basically and they'll just pluck some of
the dollar bills off of that you know a
few billion few hundred billion dollar
bills off of that very large magic money
tree and everything is fine
well everything is not fine
because we're experiencing right now
the results
of that kind of strategy and the results
are sky-high inflation and people suffer
so either the money is coming directly
out of our pockets
or it
ends up coming indirectly out of our
pockets in an even worse way
because you print the money and cause
you for more inflation
one way or another
who's left holding the bag the taxpayers
the average working man
is made to suffer
so no matter what
we come back to the question the ethical
quandary here
you made a reckless decision a bad
decision you have excuses for having
made it because you were too young to
make us and i agree you were too young
you did get scammed but you
unfortunately got legally scammed
it's legal for them to do that it
shouldn't be but it is
so that happened who has to suffer for
it you don't want to suffer for it um
but if you don't suffer the rest of us
do
and when i say the rest of us i mean
like don't think about
me think about just
average
you know uh
working class
person
at the grocery store can barely afford
groceries already and now we're going to
make inflation even worse
because you didn't want to suffer for
your choices you wanted someone else to
look i know that this this is not
popular like no politicians are going to
get up here and say this
i wish that somebody would i wish i wish
some politician would have the guts to
just go in front of the american people
and say listen bad decision was made
someone's got to suffer for it i'm sorry
it's got to be you because i i'm not
going to be responsible for making
someone else suffer for a choice they
didn't even make
if it's unjust that you have to pay back
the loans how much more unjust is it
that someone else has to rather directly
or indirectly pay them back
nobody wants to say that
uh certainly no no politician in dc
wants to say it because they don't have
the guts to say it but it's the truth
here's a guy who wants to be a
politician in dc john fetterman in
pennsylvania and he is just
not well at all um he he
simply isn't so
he's only done a couple of public events
and speeches over the last
several months and you can kind of tell
why so here he was yesterday trying to
get the crowd fired up but he's having
trouble getting them fired up because he
can't really speak um so listen
i'm honored to be standing in the shadow
of your murders at your amazing
building
do you think of the 10 homes dr oz have
has a union hall
across
their home
if you
say
you think the word
of
worker
what words come to your mind if you say
steel workers of all the words that
bring to your mind when you hear the
word steel workers
does the word predator come to your mind
that's not a word that's going to come
to my mind critique
is wrong with demanding for
an easy
safe
kind of
their
income
this is one simple and one simple truth
if you send me to washington dc and
there's going to be choices in front of
me as the next senator and it's going to
be it's going to be what
are you going to stand with we got the
idea there um but he can't speak i mean
he has brain damage
he actually does
and that should be it i mean he's he has
brain damage he can't function he's
brain damaged
but he can still win which which shows
you something about the voters in
pennsylvania but it also shows you
which is which still is a reflection of
the voters of pennsylvania um
the quality of the opposition i mean the
fact that
the republican challenger
in pennsylvania dr oz might lose to
someone who is brain damaged and can't
speak
i mean i can't think of anything more
humiliating for the republican party
than that
but this is you
you're not a serious country
when you when people like this are
elected
um
this again is like late stage
end of civilization type of stuff here
um not that john fetterman is going to
end human civilization if he becomes a
senator he's not going to do anything at
all he's basically a vegetable it's just
a symptom
of once again a civilization just giving
up on itself
that it's going to say oh yeah he's got
brain damage he can't speak he's a
vegetable but we're going to put him in
there anyway why not i mean we already
got a vegetable running the whole
country
so what's another vegetable we'll build
up we'll build a whole produce section
all right
this is from msnbc it says
representative marjorie taylor green
introduced a bill in congress on friday
that would ban gender affirming care for
transgender minors across the country
gender farming care also known as
mutilation and sterilization of children
it's the most sweeping and draconian
piece of legislation conjured by an ever
more radicalized and violent anti-trans
movement
um literally no examples of violence are
provided ever
a violent movement but
not not one example of violence
not they can't provide one example of a
quote anti-trans person
acting out violently against trans
people not one example can't do it
doesn't exist
um
i'll tell you one thing you can find
examples in the reverse
while the bill sports only 14 republican
co-sponsors its passage would likely
become a priority if the gop were to
retake congress this fall
that's another another humiliating
statement about the republican party
that only has 14 co-sponsors i mean the
marjorie taylor green bill
um and it doesn't matter how you feel
about marjorie taylor greene personally
it makes no difference
um she
this bill every single republican in
congress should support it we should
demand that they all support it the bill
is very simple and it's exactly what the
federal government needs to do it's
exactly what we need republicans in dc
to be doing or trying to do
it would simply ban
doctors from castrating or mutilating
kids
period that's it you can't do it
um
it continues since the 2020 presidential
election reactionary forces in the u.s
have increasingly become more focused uh
on trans issues physicians and staff
members at
boston children's hospitals were
threatened last week by a far-right
gender-critical internet mob that spread
lies about the facility's work with
transgender adolescents
the harassment campaign was kicked off
by shia reichik who runs the anti-lgbtq
social media account libs of tick tock
along with anti-abortion and anti-lgbtq
media personality matt walsh
both told the lie that the hospital was
performing hysterectomies on children
well that that in and of itself is alive
because that's actually not what i said
i didn't say that the hospital is
performing
is is definitely performing quote
unquote gender affirming hysterectomies
on children
there's certainly evidence that they
have
reason to think that they have but what
i actually said is
it's almost irrelevant because we know
they're doing it to 18 year olds which
is still horrifying
and by the way if an 18 year old is not
uh mentally competent
to sign on the dotted line for a college
loan and is so incompetent that we have
to forgive those loans after the fact
that merely that merely you know
presenting the option to an 18 year old
is a is a scam
well if that's the case then what but an
18 year old is has the mental faculties
necessary
to agree to get a hysterectomy for
cosmetic reasons
well that makes no sense but what i
actually said is that that's what i said
that even if it's at 18 it's still
horrifying and
besides
whether or not they're doing this
particular mutilation procedure on kids
whether or not they're doing that we
know
that they're performing cosmetic double
mastectomies on kids we know that they
are chemically castrating kids
we know that
so that's what i said
so in accusing me of lying of course
msnbc is lying not not that they care
there are any standards here at all
um we did send them something you know
saying they need to retract this but uh
there's just
all already for the media there's we
know that there's very little
accountability
and when it comes to anything in the
trans world
as we've seen they just
they have full license to just say
anything they want to say it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter how
far-fetched it is makes no difference
meanwhile there was a debate at uc
berkeley about transgenderism and i want
you to listen to
what this molecular geneticist
has to say now
you may not think you may think a debate
at uc berkeley
about uh
about transgenderism you might think
that the topic of the debate given that
it's at berkeley the topic would be like
um
are transgender people oppressed or
really oppressed will debate find out
but no in this case they actually have
someone up there who disagrees with the
whole concept of transgenderism based on
her scientific background let's listen
to a little bit of what she has to say
trans women should be legally treated as
women tell me why you strongly disagree
because i'm a molecular geneticist
being male or being female is a
developmental process you can't go
backwards
so you can't change your sex like you
cannot do that
and the truth is
that currently in california prisons and
prisons in other parts of the country
women are getting impregnated
by other women
and there's just no way that maybe this
is against the u.n
when
after world war ii there was like a
i don't remember what body
came up with this um
statue but it was
against i believe it was the hey you
cannot house female prisoners with male
prisoners because they get raped
and that's happening today
you know i go to the women's
i go to the women's
changing room at my gym
and there's a dude in there he's putting
on
makeup and hoop earrings
and this is not something a woman does
when she goes to work out
nor do women beat each other to death
but men do
you know and it's just it's possible
of course everything that she's saying
here is 100 correct
uh and it's a very sad thing that we
need to bring a molecular
uh geneticist in to explain you know
that men are men and women are women
um
housing women
with men in prison is it is one of the
most grotesque human rights violations
imaginable
almost as grotesque but not as grotesque
as chemically castrating kids
um
but the point that she makes there
because there are a lot of like slightly
more subtle things and so what she says
there about
like the fact that the you go is so if
she's in california so she probably
encounters this a lot of the gym with
the guys going into the women's uh
changing room
and they're putting on big earrings and
makeups before they work out
and she says
women don't do that
and so
you know this is something that all
women
women are already
tend to be sort of more naturally
intuitive than than men
um picking up on subtle things and this
is not you know having a guy in the
women's restroom uh or locker room
putting on the clown makeup is is not
very subtle but
i guess the point is that
like all women
they see the performance
of womanhood that's carried on by
these men and every woman
even the ones on the mo the ones
farthest to the left they see it and
they and they all know
like that is not what women do this this
isn't even a convincing performance
so i think every woman recognizes that
but they don't feel like they're allowed
to say it and even this woman
you can tell that she's emotional and
she's also
very nervous saying all of these really
true and basic things let's listen to
the rest of this
sad that
women have internalized misogyny to the
point where the man's comfort is takes
precedence over the woman's safety
there's a reason why they don't want to
be in men's prisons because men beat
each other to death women don't do that
aussie what if anything would cause you
to move to the disagree and is there
anything you heard here tonight that
would convince you
to move one line over it's okay to say
no i'm just trying to figure this out
no i have figured it out
and you're confident
i am as confident as
i am that this is my hand in front of my
face instead of yours
there is absolutely
this is
the most insane thing that has ever
happened to me in my life that women
are a feeling now
almost every single person that listens
to that knows that it's true and that
includes
almost all the people who would say
otherwise
and that that is the fundamental and
very deep frustration that everyone
feels on this issue that i feel all the
time
is that you're arguing for something
and you're arguing against people
who who know that you're right everyone
knows
that we're right
you know you're you're
sitting in front of a brick wall
standing next to someone
saying that brick wall exists and
they're looking right at it and saying
no it doesn't
but it does and you know that it does
that's why you're not actually trying to
walk through it that's why you're not
bashing your head against it you know
it's there
now what she says about internalized
misogyny um that's
you know the kind of left-wing feminist
framing of this and
whatever i mean they kind of frame it
however they want to frame it as long as
they're opposing this madness that's how
i feel about it but i will say that it's
not actually internalized misogyny it's
um
it's fear
right it's mainly just
fear
of the consequences of speaking out
against this
and uh and then it's kind of an
internalized self-loathing i think also
which which the left
you know propagates
wants people to hate themselves
because women that speak out not women
and men
we are
screamed at and hectored constantly and
we're told that you're a bigot and
you're all transphobe and you're all
these things and um
for me
given that i'm a far-right stochastic
terrorist extremist
those labels mean nothing to me i laugh
at them okay i've never felt like it's
hard for me to even relate to the people
who care about being labeled that way i
i've never cared at all
it's not gonna hurt my feelings in the
slightest
but for a lot of uh people women
especially that are more moderate and
then and then close on the left
being called those words like having
those labels applied to them really
hurts
because they've been conditioned that
way
and so that's what it is
all right
let's see we have time to mention
okay this is from pew it says more than
150 years after it was officially
outlawed in the united states slavery
will be on the ballot in five states in
november as a new abolitionist movement
seeks to reshape prison labor voters in
alabama louisiana oregon tennessee and
vermont will decide on state
constitutional amendments prohibiting
slavery and involuntary servitude in
some cases except for work
by incarcerated people advocates say the
amendments are needed to strip
antiquated language from state
constitutions and to potentially
transform the criminal justice system by
making all work in prisons voluntary
so this is what they're calling the
anti-slave the new anti-slavery
abolitionist movement
is to uh get rid of involuntary prison
work because that's slavery
and uh i found this interesting because
just recently we were talking about
slavery on the show and what is slavery
how do you how you define it
i think the only definition of slavery
that makes sense is you know slavery is
the ownership of people as property
that's what slavery is
um
which which would mean that if you own
somebody's property
and never made them work
they are still a slave like no matter
what they're doing
um it's still slavery because you have
you are owning them buying and selling
them as property that's why that's how i
would define slavery which means that
forced prison labor is not slavery
okay prisoners are not
bought and sold
maybe in a sense within the prison
environment amongst themselves or
some amount of that but but um that's
not what prison is
um
it is
it's punishment okay it's punitive
it also just makes sense i think that
you have all these people who cannot be
trusted in society
and so they need to be segregated
but then society says no you still need
to contribute like you don't get out of
this you still have to do something
you went to prison because you're a
murderer scumbag whatever
that's that doesn't magically get you
out of the responsibility to contribute
in some way to society so now we're
going to force you to
and we're going to force you to largely
as a punitive measure
work can be you know you want to talk
about rehabilitation well
you can't have rehabilitation without
work
work can be rehabilitative
suffering is rehabilitative if you force
people to work and they find some
some amount of suffering out of that
that's good
you can't you cannot have rehabilitation
without suffering that is one of the
core things that people get wrong we
talk about rehabilitating prisoners
you know rehabilitation should not be
the primary point of prison the primary
point is punitive
the second point is segregation you know
safety it's basically a self-defense
mechanism society's self-defense
mechanism
but if you're going to be depending on
the sentence if you're letting some of
these people back out then then yeah you
want to work towards some kind of
rehabilitation but you cannot do that
without work and suffering you have to
make people suffer confront and and
suffer for
their crimes well there's not going to
be rehabilitation
not only do i think that there should be
prison labor there should be a lot more
of it i mean we need to bring back
chiang chain gangs we need to bring all
that back
prisoners should be doing a lot more
labor hard labor
long hard painful labor is what
prisoners should be doing
you know just ask yourself we got rid of
all that just like we got rid of public
execution we've got already all these
things saying that they're draconian and
we're uncomfortable with them and
they're icky and i don't like them um
has the problem of crime gotten better
or worse
in the meantime
just something to think about let's get
to the comment section
[Music]
[Applause]
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
[Music]
wolfie says matt what time do you have
to wake up to be able to shoot these
amazing videos and have the editing team
do their work uh i wake up at 5am most
mornings i wake up absurdly early um
hours and hours before we actually film
and uh well i say i wake up at 5 a.m i i
should amend that and say that my wife
my wife is here she'd be quick to point
out that actually what i do is i set
um my alarm for 5 a.m and then 505 a.m
and 5 15 5 20 5 25 5 30 5 35 5 40 5 45
and then i wake up at 5 45
while the alarm goes off repeatedly in
the interim
and
my wife lays there cursing my name
that's that's my strategy but that's
it's just it's it's my process in the
morning it's all part of the process
kathleen says i was just thinking this
morning how weird internet fame is a guy
once came to play kid songs through our
library who sat at a table to sign his
autograph afterwards and no one took him
up on that
it was very obvious no one knew in the w
who in the world he was but he had a
youtube channel and thought he was
pretty big stuff oh that's
that is
oh man that's a nice that's the stuff of
nightmares sit there for the uh at the
autograph table and
no one comes up
who was this youtuber can you just tell
us who now i need to know who it was
um it is amazing
and i think the fact that we talked
about yesterday it's kind of fame is
very cheap now and uh and easily
obtained
and so that makes this problem worse
where
you know the smallest audience and the
smallest platform can go to people's
heads i've seen it happen so many times
in this business
somebody shows up they're not here that
long and they have a little bit of not
even that much like the smallest amount
of success and then next thing you know
their ego is bigger than they can't even
fit in the door the ego's he goes bigger
than the building
um
it can go though it can basically in
this in the in the business it could go
it could go one of two ways it usually
goes that
way you know being in front of the
camera just has that effect on people
where they now they just feel uh it they
it drives them insane and now they they
walk around like they're you know world
fame they walk around like they're brad
pitt right um
and that's how plugged in i am to pop
culture that that was the celebrity
reference i went with
but then it could also go the other way
where the camera becomes more of a of a
challenge where you have to kind of like
justify yourself all the time the bigger
the platform then um
sort of the more you feel you need to
work to justify the fact that you even
have this platform
i think that's a better way of
approaching it
um
let's see
there's one i wanted to get to okay
dodo says
hmm
on this occasion i do disagree with matt
on this one there are some pretty
significant voices who are children who
hung out with michael jackson who said
he never did anything inappropriate i
don't think he was ever found guilty of
anything maybe i'm wrong but i think the
only case against him was a lawsuit and
it seemed more likely that the family
was doing it for money not because he
actually did anything i'm open to being
corrected if i'm wrong well i'm glad
you're open to being corrected because
i'm going to correct you
first of all
um
the the defense of well a few of the
kids he hung out with said he didn't
rape them is really the worst defense
imaginable but this is what the michael
jackson defenders do they start listing
the kids he didn't rape i mean
think about what you're doing
so your defense is that he didn't rape
every kid he came across
and second fact that he was actually
accused multiple times
and yes accusations are not in and of
themselves 100 confirmation that
something actually happened but
okay
almost all of us can go our entire lives
without being accused of raping any
children if you have this happening a
lot
it's not just once but but this is
constantly happening to you then
something is wrong here probably
it could just be a conspiracy among the
nation's children to paint you as a
child rapist but probably not
especially when you consider
that michael jackson and this this to me
is decisive michael jackson admitted
to inviting
young boys to his house and having
sleepovers with them
sleeping in the same room and sometimes
often in the same bed now well i want to
play this interview there's a clip of
this interview that this this was back
you know this interview came out like 20
years ago and um
there's a big sensation at the time
maybe it's already been forgotten the
video quality is a little bit weird here
from youtube but all that matters is the
audio just okay you listen to this and
you tell me
if it's like uh outlandish to think that
this guy might be pedophile go ahead
he deserved all the joys of life and so
it was that we came back to our meeting
at neverland with 12 year old gavin
i'd found this easily the most
disturbing moment of the past eight
months you know some have
and they say
[Music]
is that really appropriate
when you're talking about children we
met gavin
and it was a great privilege to meet
gavin because he's had a lot of
suffering in his life yeah when gavin
was there he talked about the fact that
he shares your bedroom yes
can you understand why people would
worry about that
because they're ignorant
but is it really appropriate for a 44
year old man
to share a bedroom
with a child who is not related to him
at all that's a beautiful thing that's
that's not a worrying thing i should be
wearing who's the criminal who's who's
jack the ripper in the room
this is a guy trying to help heal a
child
i'm sleeping in a sleeping bag on the
floor i gave him the bed because he has
a brother named star
so him and star took the bed
and i'm on the floor in the sleeping bag
did you ever sleep in the bed with them
no
but i have slept in a bed with many
children i sleep in the bed with all of
them when my colleague cooking were
little
kieran culkin would sleep on this side
mccully cuck is on this side his
sister's in there we're all just jamming
the bed
okay
i mean why do people embarrass
themselves you listen to that and you
say oh it doesn't mean there's anything
wrong with it
you wouldn't be saying that if he wasn't
a good dancer if you didn't like his
dancing and the way that he sings you
would not be saying that you would not
give that kind of
leeway to any other human being on earth
if there if your neighbor across the
street
was a 44 year old man inviting little
boys over for sleepover parties what
would you think would you let your son
go over would you let your son is there
any world ever in which you would allow
your 10 year old son to go sleep in bed
with a neighbor across the street
of course not
nobody ever would why
why because you know that the chances
that something horrible is happening are
astronomically high
and so you know that for every human on
earth but you say no michael jackson's
different
why is he if anything
he he's it's it's even more certain in
his case that he was doing something
because he's the guy's a for like how
could you look at michael jackson and
say well no he's the only one who would
never do that
he's the only one who would never
how is that your judgment and not he's
he's like the most likely one out of all
of the creepy men who sleep with kids in
their bed
it's i'm sorry it drives me crazy
just stop
he's sleeping with little kids in his
bed because he because he wants to heal
them and you buy that
i'm not just by the way i'm not just
yelling at the guy who left the comment
i mean i am yelling you but just
everybody
snap out of it i mean the guy's been
dead now for over a decade can you like
has the spell worn off yet
i mean how did it not wear off the
minute he started looking like
you know like some kind of undead goblin
walking around
but it didn't i mean how okay but now he
really is dead so
you're still under this spell of of
there might be an appropriate reason
why a man would invite
boys over
he's holding hands with a young boy
there
my god
come on just just stop like
and then
so he gets him
he's he's sharing his bed with little
boys and then some of them come out and
say
he molested me
and you still won't believe it
do you actually what do you need do you
do you need to like have walked into the
room and witnessed it yourself
maybe then you would even make still
make excuses it just
it's mind-boggling
here at the daily wire we're doing
everything we can to loosen the left's
grip on culture we're making movies that
challenge woke hollywood narratives uh
documentaries like what is a woman that
exposed radical gender ideology we're
creating kids content
that parents can trust we even sue the
government over unconstitutional
mandates it's a lot of work and there's
still a long way to go but you can help
in just two simple steps one stop
shaving with your razor two
start shaving with jeremy's
oh we're doing this again with the with
like you let
yet again
here we'll go through the whole process
together they want me to hold up the
razor and yet again it's not it's the
razor is not out
so this is actually this is the whole
kit you got this is the kit that i got
from jeremy's razors
we're gonna make this a 45-minute promo
there's a there's a lot of great stuff
is this what i'm supposed to be doing
actually is going through the whole kit
or is it just the razor
oh go through the little kit okay so you
get the shaving cream
um which i hear i hear shaving cream is
great to use
i wouldn't know but
you get the post shave balm
uh which hey even if you don't shave you
could still use the post shave balm
that's what i always say and then but
the star of the show is the actual
razor
how does that work oh you have to put
the razor on the end of it
i'm learning razors along with all of
you we're all learning this together
uh and there it is that is jeremy's
razors it is
for people who shave the best razor you
could possibly ever use
um
if you're still not shaving with the
jeremy's razors chances are you're
funding leftist ideologies we're
building alternatives and the left is
betting their bottom billion dollars
that you won't use them
prove them wrong go to
jeremiesrazors.com get your founder
series shave kit today daily wire plus
members get 25 off jeremy's razors shut
up and shave now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well our daily cancellation today is
like a russian nesting doll of dumbness
you start with something dumb only to
find that there's something dumber
inside it and then something even dumber
inside the dummer thing and so on
forever ever and ever into the abyss on
final analysis when surveying the whole
web of idiocy in its entirety you're
left with something so inconceivably
ridiculous that it would be too
outlandish even as a babylon b headline
okay that's how i'm setting this up and
i and i and i don't think i'm
exaggerating
we begin here as we start to peel back
the layers on this onion of idiocy um
there was a group of computer
programmers
who invented the world's first ai rapper
okay so imagine siri or alexa if they
were drug dealers and you basically get
the idea here the robot rapper is named
fn mika
and uh he has over the past year or so
apparently released a number of songs
despite not actually existing in
physical form that is a handicap which
has not prevented him from creating
masterpieces like this one
[Music]
who knew that the singularity would be
so obnoxious
and yet it must be admitted that fn mika
also sounds indistinguishable from most
other rappers this ai generated song
is lifeless and empty and depressing and
terrible and for that reason it's
totally at home and uh amid today's
landscape of rap and pop music it's not
it's not that it's not that artificial
intelligence has become so sophisticated
it's rather that popular music
has become so atrocious this is the
great twist ending to the story of of
humanity it's the thing that no sci-fi
writer saw coming they all thought that
computers would gain souls and become
like humans
but instead
humans lost their souls and became like
computers
and because most popular music is
soulless and hollow it can be supplanted
by you know siri's ex-con boyfriend
even the pop songs ostensibly created by
human beings are still for all intents
and purposes artificially generated the
average beyonce song has like 25 writers
and yet the lyrics sound like something
dr seuss might have written if he was
brain damaged and addicted to crack
cocaine
there's no truth or beauty or soul in
any of it and so nothing is lost by
replacing modern pop stars with actual
robots
capital records certainly felt that way
which is why they signed fn mika last
week gave him a record deal making him
the first non-existent person to ever
obtain a record deal
as the website hot new hip hop noted at
the time the rapper is the creation of
brandon lee and anthony martini of
factory news which is a virtual record
label that was the first to sign the
robot martini claims that the rapper's
voice is that of a real human but
everything else about him from his
lyrics to the chords and tempo
underpinning his music is based on a.i
fn mika is a big sign for capital
records as the virtual being has over 10
million followers and a billion views on
tick tock ryan rudin of capital records
describes mika as this way it meets at
the intersection of music technology and
gaming culture it's just a preview of
what's to come
yes a preview of what's to come or so he
thought
a few days after capital records had
triumphantly announced its partnership
with a semi-literate chatbot the
partnership had
tragically come to an end
fn mika
despite not actually existing
was canceled
because he used the n-word
that's correct a non-existent artificial
robot rapper was fired because he used a
racial slur that a million actual human
rappers have used a million times a day
stereo gum reports quote capital records
has severed ties with the recently
signed ai rapper fn mika who came under
intense scrutiny after clips of the
project using the n-word went viral
social media users also surfaced an old
image from mika's instagram
showing that uh the rapper is in a scene
of police brutality
capital record set of statements cmg has
severed ties with fm mica effective
immediately we offer our deepest
apologies to the black community for our
insensitivity in signing this project
without asking enough questions about
equity and the creative process behind
it we thank those who have reached out
to us with constructive feedback in the
past couple of days your input was
invaluable as we came to the decision to
end our association with the project
well it's a good thing that they
apologize to the black community this uh
will come as a relief to all of the
ordinary black people who were feeling
deeply traumatized and emotionally
burdened by the inappropriate language
used by a wrapping computer program
except of course that no ordinary black
people were traumatized by this or even
aware of it
this was this was the work of brain dead
activists who complained that fn mica
was a caricature and stereotype of black
culture
and they're correct of course i mean
it's exactly what it was except that
most human rappers
are also caricatures of black culture
they are more cartoonish and insulting
in their case you would think the
caricature is even more degrading
because there's a human being behind it
and if the n word is objectionable which
it is
you would think that the offense would
be all the greater when an actual flesh
and blood human rapper utters it
but that's not the rule as outlined in
the book of wokeness according to those
scriptures the rules are pretty clear
the n-word is a magical incantation
which is empowering and positive when
uttered by black people but horrifying
and dangerous when it passes through the
lips of someone with a lighter skin tone
it is a combination of syllables whose
offensiveness is determined by skin
pigmentation and if you have no skin
pigmentation at all because you have no
skin because you don't exist then you're
not entitled to say the word
and that's all there is to it there's no
logic to this rule there's no sense
there's no moral coherence but there is
consistency at least
never mind the fact that the programmers
use the voice of an actual human who
happens to be black to generate fn
mika's voice
in fact it's not clear to me that fm
mika actually is an ai at all it seems
that he's essentially a computer
animated avatar
voiced by an actual person i mean he's
not a robot any more than buzz lightyear
or shrek or robot
but uh but i don't know forget about all
that
nothing needs to make sense in the world
of of the wokes golds
all they know is that they are outraged
the reasons don't matter
and today they are outraged by a
computer animated avatar and that is why
they
along with that avatar are cancelled
and that'll leave it
and that will not end it for us i'll get
used to this eventually we're going to
move into our members block of the show
and if you're not a member yet please
become one so you can join us for uh for
that segment uh otherwise talk to you
tomorrow godspeed
[Music]
so
[Music]
you